everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm today we start our coverage
of the 2020 candidates tournament winner
of this tournament does go on to face
Magnus Carlsen later in the year for the
world championship many thought this
tournament would not happen since
everything else seems to be canceled
these days but the tournament started
today and it looks like it is going to
continue we have eight of the top
players in the world it's going to be a
good one in round one we had some
fireworks particular game we're gonna be
going over why it's gonna be played by
draw master himself a nice giri and
blacks can be played by my dark horse
and that is the Magna Slayer himself
Yann nepo we're gonna get started with
Giri he plays Knight to f3
we have Knight f6 c4 c5 Knight c3 in the
knight c6 so getting into the
symmetrical English opening and then
from here we see d4 this is where we
stop the symmetrical and we are going to
see black take here on d4 you typically
don't see it go past this if you were to
see d5 then we start to see some
exchange on board then usually gonna
take the knight here then the Queen
comes off not necessarily terrible once
the Queen comes off that you are not
gonna castle anymore
but then you have two isolated pawns
here on the C file both sides have given
up so much material early on there's so
much prep work that goes into this
tournament these are typically not the
lines that you expect to see from these
players so we didn't see this instead
after the move d4 we see pawn take here
on d4 and the knight take on d4 young
continues with e6 and then we have g3
just so many different options that GE
has in this spot he could play III
opening up for his LightSquared bishop
he can even play E for if he wanted to
he could get his dark squares welcome to
the game Bishop 2 before he decides to
go ahead and play g3 preparing the
feeling kiddo his bishop here to g3 R 2
G 2 if he wants to Queen comes down here
to a b6 this is just putting pressure on
the center of the board here the knight
on d4
that comes up here to b5 now this is
putting some pressure on the queenside
for black and you have to be aware of
this position many lower rated players
would look at this and say I got a kick
this night away they may play something
like a six but really then Y can just
play d6 and then after the Bishop
business check after the Bishop takes
and the Queen comes up here and this is
just a nuisance that blacks gonna have
to deal with you can see both of these
pawns here on a d7 and b7 are blocking
the light squared Bishop the King can't
castle on the King side just not really
the best spot that black wants to be in
so instead recognizing that the threat
coming up here to d6
instead we have yon playing Knight to e5
so this is opening up the door for his
queen to also control the square here on
a d6
it's a very nice move also still allows
him to push forward with his D pawn if
he wants to get his lights for it but
should be involved into the game Bishop
comes here to f4 immediately attacking
this night here on e5 and the knight
comes down here to g4 defending this
night here on e5 pawn to e3 just opening
up for the LightSquared Bishop to get
involved into the game also gives
another option if he wants to retake
with this pawn here on f4 if there's a
capture at some point but now that black
has opened up for our Black has opened
up for the Queen to now control the
square here on the six can now freely
play a six here but there's no good
square for the knight to move here we
already talked about why you can't come
here to dese extent to bring it back
here to a3 as well so reduce did you
replay h3 and says I'll go ahead and
exchange material here you take my
knight I'll take your Knights and we'll
have double pawns you'll have on the B
file all have here on the G file and
we'll have some semi open files for both
of our rooks that's exactly what they do
pawn takes here pawn takes and you can
see send me open file for this rook send
me up and file for this rook right here
now I feel like this does favor black
and
this position you know blacks gonna be
looking to castle on the kingside he can
start to attack with his rook here on
the Queen side in this position you're
typically not gonna see white castling
on the Queen side and doesn't look as
strong now to be castling on the King
side either so it'll be interesting to
see how White's gonna continue to put a
lot of pressure on black but black I
think definitely has a better setup here
and then after the knight takes here on
a c4 black is up a pawn in material
that's gonna be difficult later on to
hold on to these double pawns here but
right now this pawn on b5 doing a good
job of supporting this night here on a
c4 that just went up that pawn and
material when you see white play rook to
a c1 and then pawn down here to defy now
if it looks like the knight can just
freely take here on b2 it's not quite
that easy because the Queen comes to b3
now the bishop here on f1 is attacking
this pawn here on b5 also the knight and
the Queen are both attacking and the
Queen is attacking this night here on b2
so it just it's a little tricky but I
can't just freely come up here because
Bishop takes here and the pawn can't
recapture here because then the Queen
would fall so that's definitely not
gonna be good for black so how does
black really continue he may play Queen
to a5 and then Bishop takes here got
that material back and B Queen to b4
castle on the Kings side after the Queen
takes pawn takes here but still this
Knights in a tough spot eventually the
rook can come here to see - all in all
definitely not the best spot that blacks
gonna be looking not to be - so that's
why instead of the Knights coming down
here to be - instead we see d5 and this
is what black was preparing even from
early on with the pawn to e6 is
extending with his pawn here on at d5
nice shiri pushes forward with pawn to a
b3 trying to force this night away and
then black comes down and plays Bishop
to b4 pinning down this Knight to the
King
also preparing the castle on the
kingside thank you they have the
opportunity just to played night ii III
don't always want to have your nights on
the a or the H file but this is down
your opponent's territory you can stop a
lot of the critical squares they would
want to get to also you can play Bishop
down here to be for later on but decides
instead go and play Bishop down here to
be for pawn takes on c4 and then rook
down to a3 don't have to take the knight
right away it is still pinning down the
knight to the king that's not gonna
change anytime soon there's not like a
bishop that can come back here the dark
square Bishop is outside the pawn chain
right here so rook down to a3 adding
more pressure on this night here on a c3
Bishop comes up to e5 now just defending
this material right here doesn't stop
the the the pin that's going on but does
protect that square a little bit more
we do have f6 attacking the bishop
bishop comes here to d4 and then queen
a5 so just adding another attacker on
the square here on c3 you can start to
see a big attack coming here and then
Bishop to e2 which I don't really think
this is adding much to white standpoint
you can see the Queen and the bishop are
both attacking this Knight that's being
pinned down to the King yes if you play
Bishop to e2 you still have the option
to castle on a King side but remember
this setup is not really meant for white
to castle on the King side I don't know
that that's what white would really want
to be doing anyway so in that case I
think you want to try something like
King to e2 just get out of the way of
this fork right here if there's an
exchange that's fine but I really don't
like just bring your Bishop here to me
too because if you like King to e2 then
maybe the pawn takes here on c4 I think
that's fine maybe now the knight comes
up here to e4 it's no longer being
pinned down by the bishop and the Queen
may be pawn to e5 this is something that
white can can definitely get out of but
after a Bishop to e2 now the bishop
takes on
three check rook takes here rook takes
and then King to f1 it's not gonna be
great if the bishop takes here you can
see Bishop take Queens going to
recapture here this is check after the
King moves black just has a pretty
dominant position here the pawn can
capture here on c4 and black is all up
in White's business after the King comes
to f1 then pawn to b4 and I do think
this is an opportunity that black could
have improved on his position he had
pawn takes on a c4 and yes the bishop
can take here but as we just looked at
after the Queen takes on c3 this is such
a dominant position from black and it's
really difficult to see how White's
gonna continue and in a good way this
pawn chain from black is very very
difficult to deal with his pawn here on
the B Falcon start to push forward he
can get light square bishop involved
into the game he can even castle on the
King side swing his rook over here to
the a file and start to attack as well
in the game instead of taking this
material right here he plays B for now
which may not want to give up that
material right away or if the bishop
takes then he's gonna recapture but as
soon as we see g5 we see II five right
here but then the bishop takes the pawn
recaptures it's so difficult for black
to hold on to this material here on c3
yes it is in a dangerous spot and
White's gonna have to deal with it but
no longer does Queen hat or black have
his Queen here on c3 having a lot of
pressure on his opponent this pawn is
not doing too much doesn't have a dark
square bishop to come over here and
defend this it's gonna be very difficult
to have his pawn here on d4 and he
doesn't have this pawn on c4 anymore
white now has that material so I don't
think this is as good a position that
black could have been in still not the
worst thing in the world
pawn takes here on f6 pawn recaptures
now the Queen comes over here to a b1
it's not doing too much I mean yes it's
attacking both the pawn here on b7 and
h7 but you know I don't I don't know how
White's really gonna continue too much
here
Queen comes up here too
see seven just stopping any sort of
shenanigans you know the rook could
potentially come up here to h7 and take
right here but this this does stop that
also can come down take here on a c4 get
the material back at some point that I
think he wanted to also defends if the
bishop still here if he wants to take
with his pawn here on a c4 so does have
some couple options here Queen to d3
pawn down here to a b5 just attacking
the square here also keeps his queen
defending this square here on h7 if he
feels like that is a long-term threat
Queen takes here on c3 as I said before
it was so difficult for black to hold on
to that material here on c3 just felt
like you would have been better served
if he had his Queen here but he didn't
so instead the pawn takes here on c4
punt up here to e4 would you see an
exchange in this air of the board and
now we have an isolated pawn that Black
has here on c4 work up here to age for
attacking the pawn bishop down to e six
defending this isolated pawn so it has
both the Queen and the bishop attacking
this or defending this and White has his
Queen and his Bishop attacking this as
well the rook takes here on e4 and now
White has three pieces attacking this
pawn right here so something's got to
give black decides to go ahead and
castle on the King side Bishop takes
here on c4 so now both sides are equal
and material this is pinning down the
bishop decides to go and bring his King
here to g7 and this is an interesting
move Queen to b3 says yeah I'm gonna put
my queen and my bishop on this long
light square diagonal and then after
rook to b8 this is where things start to
take a pretty crazy turn here because we
see the bishop take on e6 and just
leaves his queen right here so he does
get the Queen and he gives up his rook
and his bishop but this is a tough spot
for for white to deal with going into
the endgame
a queen verse a bishop and rook
typically ends in the queen dominating
so interesting to understand why nice
giri would continue down this path but
that's exactly what he did
queen comes down here to see one check
King to g2 Queen up here to c6 chases
this around the board a little bit
pushes on at the king side with h5 rook
to g8 check this is being defended by
the bishop here on b3 but pretty easy
for the king to move around no real way
to put a lot of pressure on black at all
can start to gobble up summits here
right here and that's exactly what he
does but after Queen to f3 we see rook
to h8 pawn down here to e4 just putting
more pressure on his opponent rook to d8
check after the bishop comes down here
to d1 this is going to allow rook down
here to d5 and this has the rook and the
bishop attacking this pawn right here on
h5 punt comes down and white is able to
get that material so did a lot of work
to get that pawn of material but it's
still very difficult for him to continue
here after f5 we see rook to f5 and I
think this was a mistake by white here
because it does allow black to come down
Queen to e1 check and this is gonna be
giving up this material here on it you
want so after King to g2 we see the
Queen take and yes it's nice that he has
this pawn he's gonna try to hold on to
this as much as possible but really this
Queen can do a lot of work and all these
pawns from white they have a long way to
go before they can get promoted it's
gonna be very difficult for white to
just push up the board black can stop
the King from going anywhere and the
rook all by itself against a queen is
just very very difficult to push any of
the material up now we see rook to g5 it
doesn't really save too much if you're
like and say just play rook to e5 check
you can get the pawn
yes that's true but after king f6 the
rook takes here then rook up here to d5
pinning down
the rook to the king here probably f3
supporting that but then the Queen you
just take here on a2 again black doesn't
need that pawn it does add an extra
layer of threat to the board for black
but this Queen can do all the work
gobble up all the material checkmate is
his opponent it doesn't really need that
so white looks at that and says okay I
gotta hold on to as much material as
possible
these past pawns are pretty much all I
have going for me so decides not to give
up that pawn right away play rook here
to g5 but Queen over here to a-1 there's
just no good way to stop that says okay
yeah I'll just go ahead and concede that
but Queen to be one says I'm not ready
to give up my rook or my pawn here on e4
just yet rook down here to g3 loses his
pawn we're over here to h3 so black
doing a good job of being able to gobble
up all the pawns from white and not even
giving up his pawn here on e4 and for
the rest of the game it really comes
down to just choking white out of any
potential moves here you can see that
the King is isolated can't really go
anywhere all blacks really trying to do
is get his King into a position to start
to gobble up material this pawn here on
h4 is the first square these trying to
capture here and just slowly squeezing
white out of the game here I can all I
can really do is just move the rook back
and forth but at the end of the day
that's not doing too much and so
eventually once we get to move 73 we
have White's coming here to e3 and then
Queen up here to d3 and in this spot we
have an HT re resigning in the game and
young nepo who I have as the dark horse
to win the tournament's wins game number
one now these players Mets Tata Steel in
2019 that the Masters round of you know
the top players in the world and same
thing happened with the black pieces
young won that game and his tree went on
to be +4 on the tournament's so had a
massive comeback against the top players
in the world
14 games that they'll be played in the
Canada's tournament so he has 13 games
left it's not the end the world
definitely not the start - he won
especially with the white pieces usually
have some strong preparation coming into
it he started with the English opening
something you don't see all that often
so you know he put a lot of time and
energy into this specific opening I'm at
the end of the day Yann just came out
and and had a crucial crucial win was
very interesting to see that at the very
end game the news jury went with giving
up his his Queen in exchange to have a
rook and Bishop first Queen in game
don't think that was necessarily that
the route that he would have liked to go
down but it did not end up well for him
but all know it was it was a fantastic
game we don't see something like this
too early and a lot of these tournaments
in one of the first few rounds these
wild openings that we don't see that
often a very decisive game from Black
here so hopefully guys enjoyed round
number one for anyone that was watching
it live Magnus Carlsen was giving a lot
of commentary always fun to watch him a
pretty funny guy giving analysis on
these players but getting really really
in-depth analysis but hopefully you guys
enjoyed the recap I'll be doing this
every single day they do play three days
on and then they take a day off three
days on again I'll be picking one game
from each day and giving commentary on
that but thank you guys so much for
watching and then I'll see you tomorrow
in game number two